good afternoon
invite the men to please take off their
hats in honor of the god we invoke
let us pray
oh god the father creator of heaven and
earth
sustain us
with your tender care
o god the son redeemer of the world
bring us pure and spotless
to your father
o god the spirit sanctifier of the
faithful
unite us ever more perfectly
to jesus the son
o holy god we thank you for all your
tender mercies
for our creation and preservation
for our growth and belonging
for our lives and our learning
all good gifts come from you and apart
from you we can do nothing
we acknowledge you to be the lord
and we thank you for your great glory
shed so lavishly upon us your creatures
we ask for your protection this coming
semester
protect us from division and strife
protect us from all false choices
protect us from illness
protect us from despair
protect us for your name's sake
that we might better serve you
that we might better hear you
that we might better glorify you
that we might better love you
speak peace to anxious hearts
give faith to doubting minds
give hope to uncertain souls
in the semester to come equip us more
thoroughly to do the good works you have
prepared for us to walk in
and give us that quiet trust to know
that we are always walking in your most
benevolent sight
o holy blessed and glorious trinity one
god have mercy upon us
renew our minds receive our praises
inspire our imaginations
draw our restless hearts to you
and all this we ask for jesus christ's
sake
our only mediator and advocate
amen
please face the flag with me
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
please be seated
good afternoon
special thanks to our prelude ensemble
and bagpiper and a hearty welcome to the
students and parents of the graduating
class of 2025
i'm dr chris van orman college provost
on the platform with me today are
president larry yarn
rising seniors rachel keady and soren
moody who will speak momentarily
dr mark mark haltoff dean of faculty
dr matthew young dean of the natural
sciences
dr paul moreno dean of the social
sciences
dr rj pastrito graduate dean
and read him reverend adam rick
hillsdale college chaplain
please rise with the hillsdale college
chamber choir as we sing our alma mater
you're invited to join in their
conductors our very own professor james
a holloman please stand
[Music]
your skull
[Music]
bringing
distinction true
no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
faith in life
becomes complete
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
for my soul
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
for my soul
[Applause]
[Music]
i
was sinking down
[Music]
when i was
[Music]
for
[Music]
[Applause]
for my soul
[Music]
i will see
is
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i will see
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
jesus
[Music]
so
[Applause]
thank you jim special thanks to the
members of the chamber choir
we will now hear from our two senior
students
rachel keady is a senior from khalifi
kenya our majors are economics and
mathematics and she hopes to pursue a
career in international economic
development
perhaps through foreign policy
at hillsdale she belongs to the
international club the praxis political
economy club and the intervarsity
christian fellowship
she also plays on the beach volleyball
team works at the library call center
and serves as resident advisor in her
dormitory
besides her current activities
she recently joined in a spring break
mission trip she also helped coordinate
an international studies membership or
sorry international students membership
program for the 2020 harvard african
business conference
christopher soarin moody
is a philosophy major from mount airy
maryland he plans to ultimately join the
clergy or work international missions
at hillsdale storm belongs to the
university christian fellowship and
serves both as a student ambassador for
the admissions department and a
residence advisor in the galloway
dormitory
he enjoys rock wall climbing at the
sports complex participates in the opera
workshop performs with the concert choir
and chamber choir and plays racquetball
and intramural basketball besides his
various campus activities he assists
with a youth group at the college
baptist church he recently participated
in a one-year immersion program in
belgium and learned to speak fluent
french
rachel
thank you
mrs philip the deans thank you so much
for this honor of addressing the class
of 2025
dr ahn faculty and staff
parents and students good afternoon
class of 2025.
congratulations
for joining hillsdale college
you are now united
with one of the greatest institutions in
the country and in the world
in the next four years this will be your
home
today
you have begun to be a part of this
community
one of the questions that you may be
asked these first few weeks here at
hillsdale college is
why did you choose hillsdale college
i was asked many times
but each time i wondered if there are
people who don't know
why they select a certain college
so i always responded
to study
soon
i realized that if it's just studying
then you can just you can study almost
anywhere in the world
so why
hillsdale why cross an ocean to attend
this little school in the midwest of
america
why not choose any other school in the
united states
there are few up the road that are quite
well known
i don't expect you to have defined
answers to this question today
but i ask you to ponder this question
throughout your time at hillsdale
i am confident that your answer will
modify with time through your many
experiences here at hillsdale college
i want to begin by saying you are all
outstanding each one of you
or else you would not have joined
hillsdale college
you deserve to be a student here
you have worked hard
i guarantee you that the education you
will receive will be extraordinary
it will make you a better human being
intellectually spiritually socially and
morally
your transcript may not always show a's
and sometimes even bees
wish may be something you're not used to
i am not trying to crush your dreams or
discourage you from academic excellence
i am telling you that the kind of
learning you will engage in here will
cover every facet of your life
it will shape your body mind and soul
you will practice what is taught in
class with other people
you will engage in intelligent
philosophical and theological
discussions
you will make friends who become family
you will make many decisions that will
change your life and those of others
all aspects of your life will be better
by living in this community at hillsdale
because everyone here everyone you see
sitting next to you and around you will
be beside you through it all
by the time you're in your senior year
like me now
you will look back and realize how much
you've grown in this community and why
you selected this beautiful school to
cultivate your life
today is just one of the many beginnings
that you will experience here in
hillsdale and beyond
take courage as you begin
in my sophomore year i still found
myself beginning
i took dr stewart's american heritage
class
the first week of classes
he passed around a list of cities towns
and historical places in the united
states and a blank map of the u.s
he shared that he would quiz us on this
information later in the semester
well
i can name african country easily and
talk about some of their histories and
geographical location because that is
what i learned grew up
growing up sorry
i knew little about united states
history and geography
i had to learn the 50 states for the
first time for dr stewart's quiz
i am guessing you all learn the states
and probably capitals rivers mountains
in elementary school
i asked my friends how they land the 50
states and their locations quickly
friends i was learning basic u.s
geography
i started from scratch but i'm grateful
to dr stewart for his patience and his
kindness he answered all of my silly
questions throughout the semesters and
he truly cared
this example may only apply to me
but what i'm saying is you will be faced
with circumstances where you need to
begin
like today
you will begin making new friends
wednesday you will begin classes in
subjects you may not know much about
you will begin thinking about
information and ideas you've never had
before
you will have to begin thinking about
your major and your and deciding on your
future vocation
sometimes the temptation to withdraw
will always come
but always
always remember strength rejoices in the
charge
the truth is you'll be scared
you'll be anxious in one way or another
you may sometimes even question your
abilities
allow yourself to make mistakes
if you're willing to begin and be
challenged you will develop courage
humility and grace
you will experience and feel your growth
above all else
trust god with everything
he wants to work with you
and he wants to guide you
one thing i undoubtedly needed when i
first arrived was community
i had left my entire family
all my friends and any familiar faces in
kenya
i was suddenly in a new environment in a
different culture from what i knew it
was a great deal of change for a
beginning
the hillsdale community was now my
resource and my home
it will be yours too
i was warmly welcomed with a room well
arranged and food ready for me to eat
before jetta could properly kick in
i connected with people who had left
cards in my room to express my gratitude
for their kindness
one of the families i connected with
ended up being my host family
apart from hosting me during breaks my
host family has encouraged me
through life experiences and advised me
when making some of my most challenging
decisions
these people i'm telling you about are
just members
of the community
but their love for history college
is amazing
that should tell you something about the
significance of this college to the
community
did you know that his college students
are engaged in 25 philanthropy programs
in the city of hillsdale
i encourage you to join and be part of
the great work we do for this community
we love
you will meet people there from all
places
backgrounds intellectual capacities and
cultures
and to make most of it i encourage you
to work in humility
seek to know
and learn from the people you meet
in my three years here i have learned
that there is nothing more important
than communicating
and learning with others
i realized i have experienced most of my
learning engaging with students staff
and professors
i find myself discussing dr strzeca's
theology class in the quad with friends
two semesters later after taking it
my goals decisions and hobbies have been
influenced by the people around me
it is a unique human thing to talk to
one another
this communication is how we learn to
think rationally and how we develop into
better people
in my freshman year one of the old zaray
knocked on my door and asked if i could
join her and her friends playing
volleyball
i didn't know much about volleyball i
was tired
of staying in my room though so i agreed
to join her
i wasn't confident playing at first
but the excitement that shone on my
teammate versus whenever i touched the
ball was priceless
there was lots of encouragement
and it seemed everyone wanted to teach
me how to play well
long story short
that was the beginning of many pick-up
volleyball games for me
volleyball became a means of connecting
and spending time with more people
the following two semesters i too caught
granville's class
one now one of the student deans it
became a new hobby of mine because of
these people
there are many other ways to connect
with people here at hillsdale college
for example participating in acb events
asking to join a table in the dining
hall participating in your local church
activities or even leaving your dorm
room open whenever you are in
just don't miss out on the great
community of people as that is where you
will learn the most
hillsdale will help develop your
character
i have constantly been challenged to be
humble
from the words of rick warren
to humility is not thinking less of
yourself it is thinking of your selfless
you all have unique talents and skills
so don't stop developing those
but as we live in community the
scripture councils in humility value
others above yourselves
just like you everyone here has
something to offer to teach you as you
have something to teach everyone
some people will become a light your
life and you will become a light to
others
the professors faculty staff
upperclassmen and even the people who
come be after you will play a part in
your life if you let them
students here will speak truth into your
life
it is important
that we stay involved in each other's
social and moral development
there is always more to learn from each
other
because none of us here is smarter than
all of us combined
an essential virtue of being human is
being humble
loving one another taking care of each
other and being there for each other i
pray that you'll be willing
to be present for one another
four years will go by quickly but they
will be easier with kind people on your
side
you will soon land that at hillsdale you
don't close the door behind you if
someone is behind you you hold it for
them
if someone misplaces anything they will
find it well stored in the student union
or somewhere else where they can easily
retrieve it
you will meet people who are willing to
drop everything and sit in the cold
night with you when you go on stress
mode
these are things that make houston so
special and so unique
my first week i could barely keep up
with what my professors were teaching as
you all know people speak english
differently in different regions of the
country of the world
i could barely take notes in class
because everything was happening new and
so fast i approached my professors and
explained my experiences with classes
and they were all willing to help me
transition
one professor even printed a set of
white house why questions to help me
with my reading and allowed me to write
down all the questions i had during
class to ask later
i was surprised and humble to see
professors taking genuine interest in my
studies and see me through my transition
experiences like this have shaped the
intentions of all decisions i make on
and off campus
as i conclude i hope you'll be present
intentional and humble
love one another
reach out to people whenever you start
you are not alone
don't be scared to begin
have an open mind and heart
give
and receive you will be surprised how
much you grow
in this community
so be ready to work because that work
will form your character and help you
lead others to good places
as dr ann always says
put your boots on
you will be glad you accepted the
challenge welcome to hillsday college
class of 2025 i wish you all the best
[Applause]
before i begin
faculty administration and staff
thank you for all you do
your work is truly meaningful
there was an alaskan fisherman
who one day decided to take a day voyage
and go see his family at a village down
the coast
he loaded his canoe with water food and
supplies and began to paddle the serene
sea
his family knew he was coming and
eagerly awaited his approach
they prepared his room they prepared a
feast for him
yet during their preparations the wind
began to rise
the rain began to beat the roof
the waves began to crash more violently
on the shore
a full-scale nor'easter had blown in
worried for the safety of their brother
out on the sea alone in a canoe they ran
as a family all five of them up to the
nearest hill
there they spent three hours
working
gathering materials that could burn
starting a fire under a seal skin tarp
in order to
[Music]
have something to bring him home
after three hours they had a small flame
this flame grew into a fire that grew
into a blaze that grew into a burning
sentinel that cut through the darkness
of the storm
they tended that fire until morning and
still no sign of their brother
i went to sleep exhausted
just as the sun arose
hoping
that maybe he might be saved
i promise i'll come back to the end of
the story
but first i think i'm supposed to give
you some sort of advice while i'm up
here
i'll say i'm not much one for giving
advice uh just ask my friend
who freshman year had to take me to the
er because i decided that playing
thatcherball which you'll find out soon
enough about
but playing thatcherball during
michigan's last polar vortex with my
shoes off would be a good idea
i've been around the block a couple of
times and actually still have all of my
toes
so i offer this piece of advice
class of 2025
over the next four years
build the biggest fire you can
now any experienced woodsman can tell
you that you need three things in order
to build a fire
you need fuel something to burn
you need oxygen
and you need a constant heat source or
that fire will burn out
the fuel fuel's the easy part
for you the fuel is challenge
challenge brings growth and we've got
plenty of challenge around here trust me
classes conversations
discussions with professors
service in the community or in the dorms
there's no lack of things to challenge
you here there's no lack of fuel for
your fire
second one isn't quite as evident
irony doc needs oxygen
one of my favorite things to do is to
teach young aspiring campers and hikers
how to build a fire and the classic
first mistake that they make is once
they see the flame licking the tinder
they furiously throw on a bunch of fuel
and that smothers the fire
that can happen to you
learn to say no
practice it now
say yes to some things but if you can
say no
and leave room for reflection and for
doing those things that you have said
yes to well
you'll be much happier in the end
my
one piece of practical advice to you
regarding this
and if you hear nothing else and you
want one thing to take away from this
hear this
find a day where you don't have many
obligations or responsibilities
and do not work
i know that sounds radical in a culture
maybe where you know we're all about
efficiency or progress
but do not work
you won't regret it
we need space for contemplation and
thought and for community and for
connection with our creator
and if you work work work all the time
you won't grow
keep a day special
and just as oxygen keeps a fire hot so
too that space will feed into the last
thing that is essential for this fire
you are to build over the next four
years
every fire needs heat
fire starts with a spark
and then the fire self maintains a
certain degree of heat that's why water
works to put out fires it brings the
fire temperature down puts out the fire
but we're not in the business of putting
out fires right
your heat is your why
what's your bottom line
why are you here right now
you put in a ton of work if you're
sitting here you are part of an elite
class
i recognize that
but why did you do that
why are you one of 25 percent of
hillsdale applicants that actually has
the privilege and honor of spending four
years here
why'd you do it
for me when i came in as a freshman i
was trying to
make up for the air i was breathing i
wasn't it wasn't that i had a lack of
self-confidence but
i thought that what i did determined who
i was
and i tried really hard to satisfy that
and i think a lot of success came with
that but here's the thing with
succeeding as a student
this is like a hamster wheel
the more you succeed the more you need
to succeed the more you need to succeed
it's never ending
i was never content
about two years in i was ready to leave
i even despaired of life for a little
bit
thankfully
something flipped i realized i had it
backwards
who i am
determines what i do
that identity that we have must come
first and then its gratitude or a sense
of
knowledge of that identity that allows
us to do those things and be successful
but as a philosophy major i can tell you
that deciding who you are all on your
own um all in your own reason isn't
gonna work you're like a ship without an
anchor
so for me
and i'd encourage for you i found that
who
in whose
see to know who you are you have to
understand whose you are
and i understood junior year that
jesus had already earned my place in the
world
he loved me and that was it
end of story i didn't have to do
anything else
and that told me who i was
and that launched me on a path of what i
do
and i dare you to try to put my fire out
now
because i don't have to be doing
anything to maintain it it's there and
it's burning
so i told you i'd finish the story
after the fisherman's family went to bed
the embers burned rebelling against the
moist ground around them
steaming up
in
wisps of smoke
lone canoe drifted towards the shore
paddled by an exhausted
he'd very much alive fisherman
as he arrived on shore and his family
rushed out to greet him amid the happy
sobs and joyful tears his little sister
looked up at him and asked
how did you do it
how did you survive the storm
the fisherman with a tired smile looked
down
and said
i took it one wave at a time
and at the top of each crest i saw the
fire that you had built and it gave me
hope so i could take on the next wave
class of 2025
this is my charge to you
build a huge fire
be a place where people congregate for
warmth and light
do that by challenging yourself and
growing yourself
by inserting space and rest into your
life
and by remembering that jesus has
already
earned your place in the world
everything that you do comes out of that
we the class
of 2022
2023 and 2024
welcome you with love and open arms
we invite you to join us in our active
arson against a dark
world thank you
thank you rachel and soren
by way of housekeeping details after
convocation freshmen will walk to the
tent across from broadlawn and hillsdale
street down that way
parents who've registered for the dinner
should go to the surreal center which is
back that way which is located on the
west side of campus from the
across from the student union next to
the dallas center
larry p yarn is the 12th president of
hillsdale college he received his ba
from arkansas state university
graduating with the highest distinction
he received his ma in government and his
phd in government from the claremont
graduate school
he also studied in england first as a
research student international history
at the london school of economics
and then in modern history at oxford
university
while in england he also served as
director of research for the late sir
martin gilbert the official biographer
of winston churchill
returned to the united states to become
an editor for public research syndicated
and he served as president of the
claremont institute an education and
research institution based in southern
california
while at claremont he was the founding
chairman of the california civil rights
initiative
which was passed by the california
voters in 1996 and prohibited racial
preferences in state hiring
contracting and admissions
dr arne is on the board of directors of
the heritage foundation
the henry salvatore center of claremont
mckenna college the intercollegiate
studies institute and the claremont
institute he served on the u.s army war
college board of visitors for two years
for which he earned the department of
army's outstanding civilian service
medal
in 2015 dr arm received the bradley
prize from the lynn and harry bradley
foundation
he's the member of the american
political science association
the international churchill society the
mont pellerin society and the
philadelphia society published widely in
nationals newspapers magazines and
periodicals on issues of public policy
history and political theory
is the author of three books
liberty and learning the evolution of
american education
the founders key
the divine and natural connection
between the declaration and the
constitution and what we risk by losing
it
and finally churchill's trial winston
churchill and the salvation of free
government
dr arn and his wife penelope have four
children
katie henry alice and tony
please join me in welcoming dr larry arn
thank you chris
uh it's almost time for the mothers to
cry and the fathers to pretend not to
sorry about the heat we were going to
have it in the chapel but this freshman
class is so huge we won't fit
and speaking of that class with the
class of 2025 stand up so we can get a
look at you please
thank you
i'd say better looking than i thought
they'd be
and would the parents of that class
stand up please
thank you
thank you for your kid
that's a big thing
most of what i have to say today i'm
going to say to the parents because the
class of 2025 they belong to us now
we can do anything we want to with them
it's going to be difficult
uh
the
average entering grade point average is
always 3.9 a little higher than that
this year
and the average freshman is going to get
a 2.8
and those ogres there and the faculty
they think that's too high
uh we didn't have a four point last year
as i remember and we usually don't and
we don't like that and all of you guys
who got 4.25
parents we will take care of your child
in an attitude of love
in my case especially mixed with a
certain amount of ridicule
my favorite sport is to eat in the
dining hall with the students
it's just like
going hunting on a pheasant farm where
the pheasants can't fly
and if you come to town and you want to
join me i i do it just about every day
that i'm here and you can help me do it
but you're not to defend the students
that's
they have to learn to do that for
themselves
there are two things unusual about this
class uh
one is
their own characteristics and the other
is the time in which we live
they're more of you than ever you
freshmen
too many
we're going to have to weed a few out
but you know they don't leave after they
get here i don't understand that
they come from the largest pool of
applicants we've ever had
have on paper the highest qualifications
we've ever admitted and among the
highest in the country
my
aren't they great
i will remind you now what we've said
all along and that is
you haven't done anything yet
getting in here is an achievement but
who cares about that now we got to do
the work
but the prospects for our success are
excellent
and that's partly because of what you
are
the times are unusual
i think of uh
1938 and 1860
times before great cataclysms
i learned something about how the times
affect us from the student leaders last
week because
you know to get ready for all of you
half the campus that's been away they
show up and
you know work and think and try to
figure out how we're going to cope with
you
and the
ras are a great crowd resident advisors
they've got the dark blue shards on up
there is emily oguera here
wait
i don't see her
so they come back and dean phillip diane
phillip is going to be an important
person to you
she said they sent me an email just
before i talk to them i talk to them on
a cycle every year the same thing same
time same thing
she said there
they've been out and getting their
internships
and they meet wokeness everywhere they
go
and they wonder
what's going to become of them and they
wonder how do we understand that
see that's fundamental isn't it
and that's the world we live in
and i would imagine that your presence
here in such numbers and quality
is because
we don't do that here
i'll tell you why what i said to the
to the
resident advisors was
i said
you're being encouraged to feel guilty
for something you never intended
and cannot rightly be said to have
committed it through negligence
you're told that you have feelings
of which you're unaware
if you're not a charitable person
friendly to all
you heard that from both these speakers
right now
we're here to be friends we're here to
love each other
we argue all the time around here it's
like a disease
but the arguments are liberated by the
fact that we would mean well by each
other
whoever anybody is
and see this claim that you can be
guilty of something without intent
that's just the argument from the novel
1984
or the novel darkness at noon
and it pretends very bad things
that it's coming
the history of our country is said to be
nothing but a string of abuses
but the history of our country is
populated by human beings
and that meant some of them did
magnificent things
and some of them did do terrible things
but that's the human story and if we
think it was all bad back then
and all good now
what's left for us to do
social media is a problem
it grew popular as a way to share
pictures and stories with one's friends
it has become an engine of conformity
of shallow and violent argument
and a public shaming
that's the world you grow up in
how do you get ready for that world
you have to improve your intellect and
your character
human beings are a unique being
there's nothing else like them
because
they have the capacity that is that we
share with god and the angels
and yet they have bodies
and the bodies have needs and wants and
gets tired
as rachel said sits here today some of
you frightened
you know why honor is at stake you
afraid you can't do it
you have all that
and that you have the ability to see
beautiful things because you can use
ordinary common nouns
i don't talk these days without
mentioning my new granddaughter
all of you grandparents i just want to
say i pity you
because mine's the best
and she's eight months old and i've
learned something from her that i didn't
learn from my other ones
are for
she doesn't talk yet
but she's learning to
she's practicing making the sounds that
we make
on her way to turning those into words
and you know we're just about to get a
new boxer puppy our eighth one
and he's gonna be just like the other
seven he's never gonna learn any words
but after the squink we call her little
charlotte
after she starts learning words in about
six months she's going to know all the
words
she's going to know things
that she's never seen
and things that she will never see
her soul is a human soul and that means
her color
and her sex
cannot have any significant bearing
on her quality because we are made out
of something like magic
except it's divine
so i told those senior class leaders
that and i said
do you see what you have to do
you have to learn to make that argument
about the human
about the laws of nature and of nature's
god
you have to come to know
the beautiful things and to do
the beautiful things
and that means you must become prudent
and just
and moderate and brave
and that takes practice
and it can only come from a whole soul
commitment
tomorrow uh
we'll all get together and i'll threaten
you
and then
you'll leave and go sign the honor code
i want you to know it's serious
i've only myself used it once in a
disciplinary setting
i just asked a voice did a bad thing
i said is that your signature on that
page
and he was completely defeated
before anything else happened and of
course i just forgave him he cried
he thought i was going to kill him
and you know i would have if it if it
needed doing
that boy i'm afraid i'm going to say his
name although i'm always tempted to do
it it's one of my favorite stories
i was mad because he said something rude
to the dean of women into into a woman
and we don't boys
you may never use force upon a woman in
any respect
i mean not just here
ever
it is unmanly
and he did that a little bit he didn't
do it that bad but
but he got strappy with the dean of
women
and i just set out to make him ashamed
and i did
and i did it by his own words
you see
if it was just my opinion that he ought
not to do that
what's the bearing of that everybody's
different right
he had said that that was his opinion
everything
works here
because we've all chosen this
against sparkling alternatives
understanding that this is more
difficult
and more beautiful and those two things
go together
parents you should help your kids
they'll get all upset sometimes
rachel warned about that
and
tell them to stop pointing
uh well that's what i usually tell them
i mean if i think they actually really
do have a problem i'm somewhat nicer but
uh
you don't want to get carried away with
the nice part
if they have a conflict with us
take our side
because we're probably right and if
we're not we'll adjust
and we'll tell you whatever we know
you are welcome here
students
you have been admitted admitted here
because of the promise
of quality of character and intellect
and you have been admitted amidst a pool
who had many times your number like that
you are having a privilege
that is to be a benefit to others not
just others here
this college talks to 30 million people
a month
we're charging you to be here and we
lose our shirt on that
we give the online courses away for free
to about 3 million people we're just
making a killing on that
people say you should ask for people for
money more often i say no i'm too
interested in money to do that
because first of all
people give for love right
and that means we here in this community
we are the hub
of a movement
and civilization itself is at stake in
the
movement so you frenchman
you're joining now
get your boots on
[Applause]
thank you dr
and now as we come to the end of the
ceremony i would ask all new students
and their parents to please stand as we
dedicate ourselves to the high purpose
before us
this is an important transition in your
lives and it's proper we should
acknowledge and declare our commitment
inside your program you will find the
hillsdale college matriculation ceremony
pledge
as representative of the faculty i will
read the first part
we asked the freshman at your listening
respond by reading unison the second
part titled matriculates rachel and
sauron will join you
founded in gratitude for the blessings
of civil and religious liberty hillsdale
college is a seat of higher learning
here on these grounds
generations have given themselves to the
pursuit of truth the love of wisdom and
the grace of intellect
intelligent piety
here in these halls generations have
come to perpetuate the high calling of
learning and the noble love of the good
in gratitude still and in concert with
these generations together we pledge
ourselves anew to this great purpose
hillsdale college in its zeal for
learning and its embrace of
integrity and honorable conduct commit
to students all the talents knowledge
and intelligence with which it is graced
educating by precept and example is
dedicated to the liberal education of
students in whom it trusts that learning
will rise to wisdom and that virtue will
be blessed with strength
we
the students of hillsdale college
commit ourselves to diligent study and
patient reflection
having come to learn we are proud to do
so with integrity and we'll conduct
ourselves with exemplary honor
as sacrifices past and present make
possible our education
we too become stewards of this college
for the generations yet to come
we pledge ourselves to the pursuit of
truth the love of the good
and the cultivation of beauty
for the sake of our minds and hearts
and for an ennobled society
by so doing we embrace the high calling
of liberal education
this pledge speaks our unity and a great
purpose intellectual and moral wisdom
blessed by god is the foundation of a
good and humane life and the necessary
condition of enduring liberty
may god bless us now and always as we
illuminate our minds refine our passions
and seek the good
parents please turn to your sons and
daughters now official hillsdale college
students and give them your blessings
um
um
please remain standing for the
benediction
as a boon to your journey ahead
i offer you a prayer of protection
pulled from the great wisdom of the
hebrew poets the psalms of ascent psalm
121.
i will lift up my eyes and to the hills
from whence comes my help
my help comes from the lord
who has made heaven and earth
he will not let your foot be moved
and he who sleep keeps
keeps you will not sleep
behold he who keeps israel shall neither
slumber nor sleep
the lord himself is your keeper
the lord is your defense upon your right
hand
so that the sun shall not burn you by
day
neither the moon by night
the lord shall preserve you from all
evil
indeed it is he who shall keep your soul
the lord shall preserve your going out
and your coming in
and now may the blessing of god almighty
father son and holy spirit be amongst
you and remain with you
from this time forth
forevermore
amen
[Music]
upon
[Music]
is
[Music]
the
lord be gracious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you